[Music]
the office
where showing your face every day used
to be the name of the game
[Music]
but the game has changed
to think about the office as purely a
container for your people and your
equipment is very outdated
for large multinational firms the
pandemic and hybrid working have changed
the very idea and purpose of the office
the office of today in a post-pandemic
world is a social destination
offices are being radically redesigned
this is where we build the offices of
the future the changing office is
changing the way bosses manage employees
a hybrid model requires a very high
degree of trust
and this new world of hybrid working
could shape what cities look like remote
working world effect the way we plan our
cities
here in the bustling capital of india
this design consultancy is mapping out
the offices of the future
what we do here is not only test
products but we also test design we test
human behavior we test wellness how all
of these come together to make good
design
in the past office design was functional
at best
it was simply the place where employees
went because they had to
but in management speak there's been a
paradigm shift
since the pandemic the offices of
multinational companies have had
dramatic face lifts
so our office in delhi is a prime
example of what kind of office designs
organizations are looking for in the
post-pandemic world out have gone rows
of desks and cubicles
in have come collaboration spaces and
relaxation zones and even restaurants
and bars
from ericsson and standard chartered to
boston consulting group and beam
centauri some of the world's biggest
companies have redesigned their offices
the main driver of this redesigned boom
is hybrid working
in the post-pandemic world working
partly at home and partly in the office
is now seen as the new normal by many
employees of multinational firms
this has redefined the purpose of
company offices and the reasons why
employees go there
the office of today in a post-pandemic
world is about a social destination it
is a place where
employees come in to have informal
learning and build their social capital
in the organization
in singapore fei wong is a senior
manager for a multinational firm
for her
home is now where she does her
day-to-day desk work
and the office is where she goes for
actual facetime i see the office as a
base for me to go back to so that i can
meet my colleagues have lunch with them
so it's really a place where i reconnect
where i socialize with people rather
than get work done
demand for flexible working has risen
for employees of multinationals across
the world
a study found that at least some remote
working is wanted by 76 of workers in
europe
86 in america
and 78 in asia
ben hamley is the lead on the future of
work in the asia pacific region for real
estate company jll
the office is certainly still the center
of the work ecosystem for most of the
world's most progressive companies today
but it's much more expansive it includes
much more flexible use of space and time
to be able to deliver the
needs of a future workforce
[Music]
in the post-pandemic era
many companies will need to change the
layout of their offices
and accept that employees have second
offices in their homes or elsewhere
this new concept of the office will
change how employees need and expect to
be managed
if i was looking for a new job i think
having that flexibility to continue to
do remote working will be my top
priority
even more important than salary itself
so in management speak
bosses will need to think outside the
box
and outside of the traditional office
being judged on how often you show your
face in the company office will no
longer cut it
even in parts of the world where there
has traditionally been a strong culture
of presenteeism
thinking that
we are being assessed or appraised by
attendance rather than our performance
that's a very asian culture but i see
things changing
making hybrid offices a success will
require managers to give employees more
autonomy so a hybrid model requires a
very high degree of trust between
employers and employees
now we find that to be a real challenge
for managers and that's true not just in
the asia pacific but all over the world
better management of employees who are
not always in the same physical office
will be crucial to companies ability to
retain and recruit the best talent
because what happens then is
managers start to move toward a way of
evaluating employees that's based on
their results not on the hours that
they're putting in
employees feel more engaged in their
work work quality increases it's
fantastic
however there could also be losers from
the hybrid office revolution
things may get worse for groups such as
working mothers who are likely to spend
less time in company offices
although this will be a global problem
it could be more pronounced in asia
where discriminatory attitudes towards
working mothers tend to be worse than in
western europe and north america
we already have a great deal of gender
inequality
hybrid work could carry a risk that the
inequality would become even greater
hybrid work may not only change office
management cultures and office designs
it could also lead to multinational
companies building more offices
namely smaller and more local ones
in the commercial property trade this is
known as the hub and spoke model
so as companies have become more
comfortable with hybrid work the concept
of having multiple locations that all
form part of that office ecosystem has
become much more popular
one of the driving forces here is
reduced appetite for commuting into city
centres
in singapore only 30 of workers have
returned to their offices in the central
business district since the pandemic
and this pattern has repeated in cities
across the world
in the city of london office vacancies
have nearly doubled since the last
quarter of 2019.
in hong kong office vacancies have
doubled
in bangkok they have also doubled and in
paris le de france office vacancies have
nearly tripled
this trend could mean more offices and
co-working spaces popping up in
residential areas
not least in asia where large
multi-generational households are common
and space to work at home can be at a
premium
employees will increasingly want office
options closer to home
those locations not only attract
more
competitive businesses but they also
attract more
competitive talent
changes to the concept design and
location of offices could have wider
repercussions for the look of cities
in countries across the globe urban
planners are returning to design models
which incorporate concepts used after
the industrial revolution
back then businesses and industries were
often found close to or in residential
areas
before the arrival of the car changed
this
in the last
150 years
the
cities has evolved from one that
is very mixed in function into cities
that are becoming more and more
segregated but we are beginning to see a
reverse in this trend we live work play
learn etc
in close close proximity
now urban planners in singapore are
pushing design concepts like the
15-minute city
five-minute city and even one minute
city where all daily necessities are
within easy reach
although singapore has often been ahead
of the curve in urban planning
this trend could become more global
there's really no reason why
offices cannot be
mixed with residential
and
i think it will be a win-win it's not
just the individual but it's individual
community and business
hello i'm tom standage deputy editor at
the economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]